[Music]
on their 20th birthday identical twin
astronauts volunteer for an experiment
Terra will remain on earth while stellar
will board a spaceship stellar ship will
travel at 86.6% the speed of light to
visit a star that is 10 light-years away
then return to earth at the same speed
as they prepare to part ways the twins
wonder what will happen when they're
reunited since a Lightyear is exactly
the distance light can travel in the
year sailors journey should take 23
years but from having studied special
relativity the twins know it's not that
simple first of all the faster an object
moves through space the slower it moves
through time compared to an unmoving
observer this relationship can be
quantified with something called the
Lorentz factor which is defined by this
equation and secondly the length of a
moving object as measured by an observer
at rest will contract by the same factor
at 86.6% the speed of light the Lorentz
factor is 2 meaning time will pass twice
as slowly aboard the spaceship of course
stellar won't notice time slowing down
that's because all time-based processes
in the ship will slow down as well
clocks and electrical devices
Stella's biological activities including
her rate of aging and her perception of
time itself the only people who could
notice time on the moving spaceship
passing slower for Stella would be
observers in an inertial or non
accelerating reference frame like Tara
back on earth thus Tara concludes that
when they meet back on earth
she'll be older than Stella but that's
just one way of looking at things
because all movement is relative Stella
argues it would be just as valid to say
her spaceship will stand still while the
rest of the universe including Tara
moves around her and in that case time
will pass twice as slowly for Tara
making Stella the older twin in the end
they can't each be older than the other
so which one of them is right this
apparent contradiction is known as the
twin paradox but it's not really a
paradox just an example of how special
relativity can be easily misunderstood
to test their theories in real time each
of the twins agrees to send a burst of
light to the other every time a year has
passed for them unlike other objects the
speed of light is always constant
regardless of an observers reference
frame a light first sent from Earth will
be measured at the same speed as a light
burst sent from the spaceship regardless
of whether it's on its outbound or
return trip so when one twin observes a
burst of light they're measuring how
long it took the other twin to
experience a year Parsi plus how long it
took for the light to travel between
them we can track what's happening on a
graph the x axis marks distance from
Earth and the y axis tracks the passage
of time from Terra's perspective her
path will simply be a vertical line with
distance equal to zero and each tick on
the line equivalent to a year as she
receives it
Stella's path will stretch from the same
origin to a point eleven point five
years in time and ten light-years in
distance from terror before converging
again at zero distance and 23 years time
at her first one-year mark
Terra will send a pulse of light from
earth towards Stella's spaceship since
light takes a year to travel one
Lightyear its path will be a 45 degree
diagonal line and because Stella is
traveling away from it by the time the
light catches up to her over seven total
years will have passed for Terra and
over four for Stella by the time Stella
observes Terra's second burst she will
already be on her return journey but now
since she's moving towards the source of
light it will take less time to reach
her and shall observe the bursts more
frequently this means that Stella
observes Terra aging slowly for the
first half of her journey but aging
rapidly during the return Hoff meanwhile
for Stella
it seemed as though Terra the
destination star and the whole universe
are moving around and because of length
contraction
Celer observes the distance between them
shrinking by a factor of two this means
each leg of the trip will only take
about six years from stylus perspective
when she sends the first signal to earth
two years will have passed for Tara
Stella will send for more light birth
during her outbound journey each one
from farther away by the time Tara
observes the first pulse from Stella's
inbound journey over twenty-one years
will have passed for her for the rest of
Stella's return home Tara receives
multiple light bursts each year thus
Tara observes Stella aging slowly for
about 90% of their 23 years pot and
aging rapidly during the last 10% this
asymmetry accounts for why the paradox
isn't really a paradox although each
twin witness's time both speeding up and
slowing down for the other Stella sees
an even split
while Tara see Stella aging slowly for
most of the time they're apart this is
consistent with each twins measurement
of the space voyage which takes 23 earth
years but only 11.5 has experienced
aboard the ship when the twins are
reunited Tara will be 43 years old while
Stella will be 31 where Stella went
wrong was her assumption that she and
Tara had equal claim to being inertial
observers to be an inertial observer one
has to maintain a constant speed and
direction relative to the rest of the
universe
Tara was at rest the entire time so her
velocity was a constant zero but when
Stella changed her direction for the
return journey she entered a different
reference frame from the one she started
in Tara and Stella now both have a
better understanding of how space-time
works and as twins who are 11 years
apart in age they're a perfect example
of special relativity keep flexing your
relativistic muscles with this ted-ed
series about space-time replete with
black holes space-time diagrams and a
load of wibbly-wobbly timey-wimey stuff
[Music]
you